hey guys day seven of self-quarantine
yeah but everything's gonna be okay
because gal gadot sang imagine with a
bunch of celebrities man hey Wonder
Woman here's what I wonder why you don't
shut your trap and that a real hero
raise the spirits of America let me see
this [ __ ] song imagine there's no
heaven no heaven people are [ __ ] dying
that's a stupid thing to say
who wrote this [ __ ] I'm gonna I'm gonna
change the lyrics imagine their edge I
having and everybody gets to go no he'll
be Louis because that's a fairy tale Oh
both us only sky you know imagine oh the
tea tree and a spoon and you may say I'm
a dreamer he has that but but but but
that last night I did have a dream we
all went extinct like the dinosaurs well
I hope one day you join us you know like
a weird cult nothing to kill or die for
unless you're a [ __ ] rat then you get
[ __ ] white had no religion shabad are
too in the world we'll let this one we
[Music]
imagine there's no China great whoa
terrible people
solid ages imagine your husband
literally doesn't know how to wipe his
own ass Megan its side to side right oh
my god I hope someday if you go on
Facebook and give me all your data of
the world will be the world
let's just go to Mars it's pretty cool